Olivia Pratt Corbell was shot and died
in her own home
she was nine years old
now police have charged a man from
Liverpool with her murder
the crime prosecution service has
authorized merseyside police to charge
Thomas Cashman 34 from Grenadier Drive
West Darby with the murder of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell
also the attempted murder of Joseph knee
and Cheryl Corbell on the 22nd of August
2022
Cashman additionally has been charged
with two counts of possession of a
firearm with intent to endanger life
I have further authorized the police to
charge Paul Russell 40 from snowberry
Road West Darby with assisting an
offender
Olivia was murdered in Liverpool on
August 22nd her mother Cheryl was also
injured shot in the wrist when a gunman
chased another man Joseph knee into
their house
it's been six weeks since Olivia Pratt
Corbell was fatally shot in her home and
now we have the most significant
development into the investigation of
her murder but police here at merseyside
Police Headquarters are still appealing
to the public for any information
at the beginning of the investigation we
were affirming our commitment to finding
all of those involved in this case
this includes the people who tried to
shield and protect individuals and those
who prescribe the weapons and indeed
those who are hiding the weapons used in
this attack
I therefore still need people to come
forward and speak to us
both men Thomas Cashman and Paul Russell
will appear at Liverpool magistrates
court on Monday Catherine evertotsi's
Sky News in Liverpool